اطلقت بعثته منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه في
كابول مشروع توزيع الحزم المساعدات
الانسانيه بالتنسيق مع مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه وجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر للافغاني هذه المساعدات الانسانيه
ستغطي معظم المقاطعات افغانستان التي
تضررت بشده من الفيضانات والكوارث
الطبيعيه وموجات من الثلوج الكثيفه
والبرد القارس وهم اخواننا واخواتنا نشعر
بما يشعرون به
اشترك في مراسم اطلاق المشروعي المسؤولون
حكوميون والرئيس جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الافغاني الذي شكر القائمين بهذا المشروع
واصفا اياه بانه مشروع كريم سيؤدي الى
اغاثه الكثير من الشريحه الضعيفه في البلد
الشعب السعودي
ومرسي مركز الملك سلمان
وممثلين المنظمه التعاون الاسلامي على
مصاعد بمسابقه الافغاني في الحالات الضيقه
نشكر جميعا
ذبيح الله احد الذين استلموا حزمه من هذه
المساعدات يقول ان الفقر والاعتزاز
والبطاله انتشرت في افغانستان وان هذه
المساعدات ستخفف من وطاه الشتاء القارس
الذي حل في البلد
التي تحتوي عليها هذه الحزمه ففي هذا
الشتاء الا لملك شيئا لا نقود ولا دخل لنا
عشان انا قلت الكوره الحمله التصاعديه
الاغاثيه هذه في وقت تضرب البلاد كوارث
طبيعيه وموجات من البرد القارس الذي تودي
بحياه العشرات من النساء والاطفال الذين
هم في امس الحاجه لمثل هذه الحملات
الاغاثيه عبد الاله نادر العربيه كابول